problema número 6 se a efe la función
definida por fx la cual tiene dos
opciones para x menor o igual a 0 es uno
menos 2 x y para x mayor que 0 es el ala
menos 4 x muestra que f es continua en x
igual a 0 para que algo sea continuo en
x igual a 0
veamos qué pasa supongamos que esté aquí
es mi eje x y aquí tenemos el eje
y nos interesa saber qué pasa en x0
supongamos que esta es nuestra función
yo no sé en particular para este
problema no sé quizás en particular se
ve así
no más bien quizás es de esta manera
como se ve
bueno no importa lo que nos interesa
saber es qué está sucediendo en x0 así
es que para que la función sea continua
en cero
el límite cuando nos aproximamos por el
lado izquierdo
el límite cuando x tiende a 0 por la
izquierda de la función de fx el
siguiente límite cuando x tiende a 0 por
la izquierda de fx tiene que ser igual a
efe en 0 la función evaluada en 0 la
cual a la vez tiene que ser igual al
límite cuando nos aproximamos por la
derecha es decir el límite cuando x
tiende a 0 por la derecha de f de x y
esto es importante porque 7 de cero no
fuera igual estos límites tendríamos un
hueco aquí pudiera ser que los límites
existieran que tuviéramos el límite por
la izquierda
coincidiendo con el límite por la
derecha y que tuviéramos un hueco ahí
decir vite por la izquierda y el límite
por la derecha coinciden pero si la
función ahí no coincide con ese valor de
los límites si es igual a cualquier otro
valor entonces la función no es continua
ahí es por eso que el valor de los
límites tiene que ser igual al valor de
la función ahí para que la función sea
continua veamos entonces si estos
valores son iguales primero pensemos en
el valor de la función ahí
entonces veamos inciso a efe de 0 para
evaluar la función f de 0 tenemos que
ver en esta primera rama donde x es
menor o igual a 0 de tal manera que f de
cero es igual a 1 - 2 seno no puse el 21
menos dos seno de cero seno de cero es
igual a cero dos seno de cero es igual a
cero todo este término se hace cero 1 -
0 es igual a 1 consideremos ahora que
sucede con el límite cuando x tiende a 0
por la izquierda el límite cuando x se
acerca por la izquierda 0 de la función
fx y el límite cuando x tiende a 0 por
la izquierda de fx lo tenemos que
considerar cuando x es menor o igual a 0
de nueva cuenta es cuando x menor o
igual a 0 este límite va a ser el límite
cuando x tiende a 0 por la izquierda de
la función 1 - 2 seno de x
seno de x es una función continua
entonces el valor de 2 x cuando x tiende
a 0 va a ser el valor de 12 no de 0 que
calculamos aquí por lo que esto es igual
a 1 así es que el valor del límite
cuando se aproxima 2 por la izquierda es
igual al valor de la función hagamos
ahora el límite cuando se aproxima por
la derecha es decir para valores de x
mayor que 0 entonces calculemos el
límite cuando x tiende a 0 por la
derecha de fx ahora tomamos valores de x
mayores que 0 estamos en este caso aquí
por lo que esto va a ser el límite
cuando x tiende a 0 por la derecha de la
función era la menos 4x así es que esta
función para los valores que nos
interesan de hecho para cualquier valor
esto es una función continua esto es una
función continua por lo que a la menos 4
x va a ser igual a la menos cuatro por
cero y a la menos cuatro por cero es
igual a 1 esto es igual a 1 si es que la
función evaluada en 0 es igual a 1 el
límite cuando se aproxima 2 por la
izquierda es igual a 1 el límite cuando
se aproxima 2 por la derecha es igual a
1 y la función es por lo tanto continua
es igual a cero